plus de trois mètres de haut
quatre mètres cinquante de long et une
tonne de métal une sculpture monumentale
qui va prendre son envol ou plutôt son
bateau acheté par un collectionneur
américain elle partira par voie maritime
le 5 octobre pour rejoindre new york
une fierté pour son créateur c'est assez
plaisant parce qu'à la fois je l'amène
aujourd'hui je travaille sur une herbe
se fabriquait qui m'appartient plus et
je suis en train de la deûle à refaire
une beauté avant qu'elle qu'elle le
quittait définitivement l'atelier c'est
une structure qui fait 2 cinq d'affilée
avec une géométrie qui m'est propre
cette pièce réalisée il ya six ans
inscrits dans le travail de nicolas
sanhes sur la ligne et l' équilibre une
réflexion débuté il ya une dizaine
d'années elle est aujourd'hui devenue
l'écriture artistique du sculpteur afin
de supporter le voyage la sculpture et
retravaillé il ya un peu de brouillard
ce qu'on appelle encore passé à peinture
sont des petites et retombées de
particules nature qui viennent se coller
au dernier moment et d'écouter un petit
peu abrasif donc la lèze et
ce qui va permettre au vernis d'avoir
une meilleure approche on s'est brossé
nettoyer un vrai lifting pour cette
pièce un peu abîmée par ses différents
déplacements
elle doit être parfaite avant son départ
un périple qui va durer trois semaines
jusqu'à new york
elle rejoindra ensuite la collection de
l'acheteur à miami